thank you for the introduction and for
the honor of inviting here to tell you
about research that Michael
and many people all over the world have
been doing over the past few years
tackling some of the pressing realities
of information security and the way we
build computer system systems let me
start with a bit of motivation but
otherwise doom and gloom proclamations
that will motivate the later promise of
salvation by snarks so we have numerous
threats to our computer systems we have
bugs we have random failures the
proverbial cosmic rays Trojan horses
even when we don't we're not supposed to
have this the way things were designed
there are our supply chain issues that
can induce this along the way and each
of these applies at the level of user
software at the level of the hardware at
the level of the platform software
that's in between the hypervisor or an
operating system even the physical
environment surrounding the computer as
a physical device each of these has
numerous examples for the way it can be
exploited each of the combination in
this Cartesian product has made it to
papers news and exploitation in the real
world and moreover in the most extreme
case we have scenarios when we're not
supposed to trust anyone we might be in
a network on a trusted peers that may be
adversarial to us in a game theoretic
sense or economical sense or national
sense and each of these can compromise
the integrity content the neutrality
availability of the information produced
on these systems just to give one
example of a combination of these
vectors and one that we pursue in my lab
consider the matter of extracting
information from a computer using
physical leakage the computer is sitting
there maybe executing algorithms that
are perfectly secure to the best of our
knowledge and yet it is a physical
device that interacts with the
environment by emitting electromagnetic
waves by a changing its power
consumption by creating noises by
changing the electric potential on its
ground wires and so on and each of these
can and has been used for extracting
secret keys out of computers it can be
by touch of hand to measure electric
potential or by putting an alligator
clip on some rounded wire it can be just
by putting a sticker under someone's
cellphone and measuring the
electromagnetic emanations from its
voltage regulator or acoustic emanations
measured from across a classroom using a
microphone observing the vibrations of
capacitors as some cryptographic
operation is running and conveniently
even a small say my edible implements
that is a piece of pita bread that can
be used to measure electromagnetic waves
and extract secret keys and when I say
extract security keys well you may
recognize some of these logos this these
are some of the systems that we
successfully attacked very common
software very common Hardware algorithms
such as Irish say elliptic curve
diffie-hellman el-gamal elliptic curve
DSA all of these have been broken by
these means and this is just one
research group and its collaborators so
there's a there are thousands of papers
showing how more can be done
switching over to integrity well in this
case let me appeal to the popular media
that tells us how even the United States
Department of Defense cannot fully
verify the hardware that it's using to
run its critical computations for
example in the field and of course it
goes both ways
we know that the NSA is retaining the
favor by adding features to a shipments
and router to their customers so how can
we ever trust something that comes out
of with the computer when this is the
reality that we face how do we know that
it hasn't clicked how we know that it is
correct
so taking a step back we have a great
challenge here and the traditional ways
to cope with it are essentially to be
very careful be very sure about where
you buy your hardware where you
subcontract your software make sure that
everything is carefully certified and of
course bear the expense of that which is
item variable so even the NSA I am told
no longer maintains its old fab it can
no longer produce its old chip chips so
what what our small company is supposed
to do what our citizens supposed to do
to protect their information and what
are we all supposed to do in those very
sorry environments of network protocols
so I want to make a case that modern
cryptography offers us wonderful tools
to cope with this problem ways by which
instead of certifying every component we
can just use the magic of modern
cryptography to somehow get the
properties we want a posteriori and this
equals both general tools and theory
studying where we can apply this
technique in such techniques when do
they even make sense when they are a
possibility principal and underwater
sumption and applications to specific
cases where the things are have a need
and if efficient enough for execution
and in this talk I will focus on the
latter and for the case of verifying
computation now the primitive way we'll
discuss the cryptographic primitive is
called snark for succinct
non-interactive argument of knowledge
and we will dwell on the acronym in a
bit but first very informally this is a
way to convince an untrusted party of a
computational claim by sending them a
proof of that claim that is short and
easy to verify pictorially we have a
proven and verifier there is some
computational claim
expresses declaimed that some specific
function ran on some specific input and
some additional witness input outputs
some output why the claim is that there
exists at such witness for which these
wholes and instead of just trusting that
the claim is true snarks let you produce
proofs of it's true of its truth now we
could go both way two ways we could
drill down into the formalities of these
statements or we can just show a
definition by example motivating each of
these properties and that's the track
that we'll choose today so I'm going to
motivate the study of snarks by a system
called zero cash decentralized anonymous
payments from bitcoins and some of you
may be aware of it and may also be aware
that it's currently being commercialized
and deployed maybe wondering am i
plugging my stake in some company well
it's the other way around
the reason that deployment is happening
in the first place is that zero cash is
the wonderful example of the power of
snarks what they're good for and the
properties that are make the most
pertinent to applications so let's drill
in just to avoid any shade of doubt or
shadow of doubt I will stay consistent
to the original academic paper so for
those who are familiar with Z cash the
digital currency I will use different
notation and simplified constructions so
bitcoins privacy problem I guess
everyone here is familiar with Bitcoin
but how many of you are aware that
whenever you use Bitcoin you are
essentially broadcasting your
transactions everywhere okay about the
forth of the audience here and let's see
why bitcoin actually does that horrible
thing and whites inherent so in Bitcoin
every
coin every piece of currency is
represented by knowledge of a number and
payment is represented by sending that
number and that means that the number
can be sent over and over to different
merchants and they would all accept it
this is called the double spending
problem which is obviously very bad for
the for the currency so the way this is
solved by Satoshi nakamoto's scheme is
using the blockchain app logic public
ledger where every transaction is
broadcast in real time and this makes
double spending detection very easy we
just make sure whenever we accept the
payment that the the source of the funds
forward for this payment hasn't been
used before and then we broadcast that
payment to make sure that others will
know that it's already spent specifics
of this and the assumptions under which
it works are somewhat less trivial but
just by saying this we already see how
inherit it is to publish every detail of
every transaction who paid whom and how
much and that means that we've
completely lost privacy great a consumer
is broadcasts their purchases merchants
broadcast their cash flow account
balances are revealed not something but
we would accept in a regular payment
scheme a regular currency but with
Bitcoin it has so many other advantages
that this seems to have gone
unappreciated for a while now those
familiar with Bitcoin should object and
say that it's not people's names that's
written there it's only pseudonyms or
keys that they can invent but in
practice most users especially those
that have nothing to hide use few
addresses and therefore are easy to
track and there are numerous works
showing how the a transaction graph can
be analyzed to extract information it's
also a risk to differentiability of the
currency the fact the fact that coins
can be distinguished and their history
can be told meaning they may assign
different value which encounter me is
another from the mental tenant of
currencies
so zero cash the scheme with the oil
sketch is a privacy-preserving protocol
that provides all of the functionality
of Bitcoin but if you look at the
blockchain what you see is a bunch of
meaningless values random numbers cipher
texts and zero knowledge proof that we'd
get to in a second that reveal nothing
and someone standing on the side the
third party knows nothing about where
who paid whom and how much in every
individual transactions only those in
love with the intersection or relates
details and of course and essentially
they know that it's legit and jumping
ahead but just to set the stage the
system is practical proofs are a few
hundred bytes long they take a few
milliseconds to verify in less than a
minute or until pickle computer to
create there are some system parameters
that are a bit annoying but practical
everything works out there is a trust
assumption that is needed in order to
create those system parameters the
public parameters I will discuss that
later
and there are cryptographic assumptions
so the the underlying cryptographic
scheme namely the snark will require
some computational assumptions about how
simple some specific simple problems are
hard to solve and from data security of
the whole system follows now why do I
even mentions your cache and what does
it have to do with snarks so here's a
cartoon version of the scheme and I
start by the serious of very simple
constructions starting a very very silly
one a then getting to one that's
actually secure but they vary but
doesn't have much functionality and then
again I'll give a glimpse into what the
full thing looks like along the way we
will appreciate the needed properties of
snarks so here's the scenario
we look at a specific transaction and
there's a sailor in a merchant a sailor
the American sort a a consumer and a
merchant the consumer wants to transfer
it goes through the merchant so he just
tells emergency the merchants here are
42 bitcoins represented as some number
and the merchant looks at that and has
no idea whether that number is okay or
not it the legitimacy of that number
relates to how it connects to previous
transactions and is it a correct
withdrawal of funds from a prior
transaction now the consumer knows that
information so they could just say send
that information about where they got
the money to the merchant for the
merchant to verify that's essentially
what happens in meat coins in Bitcoin
that loses privacy and we don't want
that
well imagine instead if we could somehow
bring in a magical accountant that would
look at the consumers books and verify
them and make sure that the money is
correctly transferred into this payment
and then the accountant would send a
signature to the merchant well if the
accountant is available and trusted then
that satisfactory and it needs to be
trusted both by the merchants that he
doesn't really sign and by the consumer
that it doesn't link the information
these are big assumptions it's very
awkward so let's see if we can somehow
emulate this digitally so key point is
that these account that has an algorithm
that he's supposed to run and once we
are in the realm of algorithms and
computations then we can create we can
create proofs that the algorithm run
correctly and that will substitute for
the physical accountant and let's see
what properties we need for this proof
to a to a give the a properties needed
by the surrounding crypto system and so
I might have surrounded crypto currency
in our setting so let's generalize this
just to avoid speaking more about
accountants and it books what we have
here is some 4np statement of the form
showed before and there's an MP witness
and there's an MP decision algorithm and
we want this system the producing the
proof to actually be proof system in the
sense of providing soundness we're going
to relax this to computational soundness
namely soundness against any cheating
prover that is computationally bounded
asymptotically runs in polynomial time
concretely bounded by some specific but
running time under well accepted
cryptographic hardness assumptions so
the nickname for computationally sound
proofs is arguments we're going to use
that the next property we want is for
the proof to be non interactive truly we
don't want too much back and forth but
in this case in the context of a
cryptocurrency these proofs are going to
end up on on the public ledger on the
blockchain and other people are going to
check them and a pro-consumer can't
interact with everyone into the future
going forward so it must be something
you can write down on interactively next
it must be what's called a proof of
knowledge meaning that it's not just
that there exists a witness for the NP
statement but the consumer actually
knows it it's not just that there could
have been transactions leading to this
payment but the consumer actually knows
that those transactions and the
corresponding secret keys that are
embedded into them as proof of his
ownership of the coin this is a thermo
technical condition that is essential
and that's why we had the proof of
knowledge requirement more immediately
we want sickness and in the sense of
short proofs and easy verification
that's important because they end up on
the blockchain and everybody has to
verify them to make the D blockchain is
correct if they want to be really
convinced and conveniently enough if you
take this sort of acronym what you get
is
gnarrk and these are the essential
properties there is one more property
which is zero knowledge and that's the
property that the defends our consumer
from leakage of his secrets because it
could have been that these proofs
actually leak everything that is dear to
the consumers privacy maybe the proof is
simply a copy of those books right that
would be sound so we want there's your
knowledge property that says it doesn't
happen the formal definition is
counter-intuitive on the first dozen
times you hear it but essentially it
says that anything the verifier the
merchant could have learned sorry
everything he learns from the proof he
could have learned just by emulating the
proof using the information it already
has so zero knowledge snarks that's what
we're after ZK snarks and there's quite
a few of them in the literature if you
look back the term snark is modern but a
variance of these and precursors have
been studied for several decades and it
started with questions about a from the
fundamental properties of computation in
the theoretical sense Ken computations
be summarized in two short proofs in
principle it's very strongly relates to
probabilistically checkable proof so
motivated until recently mostly by
hardness results in theoretical computer
science and yet all of those a older
type of snarks or precursor to snarks ii
they follow the certain pattern which is
basically taking probabilistically
checkable proofs and then applying some
lightweight cryptography to compress
them this unfortunately wasn't very
efficient
just because those political checkable
proofs while polynomial time which is a
marvelous theoretical discovery are too
slow in practice the exit for a long
time it was polynomial in the sense of n
to the seventeen now we know how to get
it down to poly logarithmic but the
concrete numbers are still not conducive
to the kind of applications I show but
much more recently there's a crop of neo
snarks that have a trade off they
introduced some pre-processing or common
reference string that is created in
advance and in exchange for that they
are much more efficient and these are
the ones that are used by zero cash and
buy in most other applications
so let's look how these are used for
used is your cash so suppose you have
such a snark and you want to create a
cryptocurrency the first thing you think
to do is to just issue tokens give
people random numbers and say your
knowledge of the random number
represents a your ownership of some unit
of currency and in order to mint to
create a new and a random number you
prove that you spent some resources say
put into escrow some Bitcoin and then
you get the serial number and all of the
serial numbers up are public and then
when you want to withdraw or to spend
such a coin you would just publish the
serial number and say hey this is real
number that is in the public ledger I'm
entitled to something in return right
this would be the spending event
unfortunately this is very insecure
because everybody sees those numbers so
everybody can say ok that one's mine
that one's mine and get or and get to
spend other people's money we can't do
that
here's a very nice idea but son they're
in touch ma that fixes the first problem
in that is to user cryptography
commitment scheme a function that has
two inputs in our case the serial number
and the commitment randomness it
produces a commitment value for the coin
and if you haven't seen this before just
imagine it's a very random looking hash
function that heuristic Lee would do and
the way that we issue coins now is by
saying I am entitled to a new coin
because I gave something in return and
here is my coin commitment for that coin
under the hood what I did is I came up
with a serial number and commitment
randomness random through the commitment
function and they got the commitment
value for the coin which I published and
what what goes in the blockchain is just
those commitment values so you see
there's some notation here and color
coding the brown stuff is what I keep in
my private wallet that's proof of my
ownership and the blue stuff is what's
in the public ledger
now when the day comes to spend the coin
I'm going to say hey everybody I am now
going to use one of those coins whose
commitments is in the ledger so here's
the serial number of the coin here's the
randomness and here's the commitment you
can make sure that the community is in
the ledger and you can make sure that if
you plug serial number and randomness
into the function you get the claim
value okay very elegant but there's
still a problem here and that's that
I've just revealed the relation between
my spending event and the minting event
because this commitment value in the
spending event can be linked to the time
where the same value was added to the
ledger so that breaks privacy that means
the someone who observed that
transactions can link the spending and
demanding but now we are in a better
shape to use your knowledge proofs and
here's what we're going to do we're
going to build a hash of a to run the
hash a on
I'm sorry I'm a bit sleep-deprived we're
going to row or a use a hash function to
build a miracle hash tree over all of
these commitments and for those who
haven't seen this you just take pears
and apply the hash function recursively
to get the root and this it forms a
commitment to the value for everything
in the ledger
now the so forth everything is public
now in order to spend a value is to
spend the coin I reveal its serial
number and I want to convince everyone
that I know the r and c a.m. that match
the serial number without revealing the
CM but this is this is something that we
can express as an algorithm the the fact
that a given CM is in a tree whose root
is given it's something that we can
write a an algorithm to verify and
actually because it's a tree structure
we can verify it very efficiently in
size logarithmic in the in the in the
number of commitments so far so we end
up with the statement saying that the
commitment is in the tree and it matches
the RDS and this statement we can verify
in zero-knowledge
and that would and that would give us
the requisite properties let's have one
more run over the properties of the
snarks to make sure that we got them
right we need soundness we need it to be
non interactive we need the zero
knowledge to protect CM that gives us
privacy and we need enough knowledge
because of the computational hardness of
finding collisions in the hash function
that's the technical condition and we
need two Sigma's for efficiency okay so
this is the cartoon version of how we
use narcs in a geocache like protocol
but now that we here we have the power
of general NP statements and with great
power comes great functionality because
now we can extend this tuple of value
and relation
between them to add additional values in
additional relations to get more out of
our cryptocurrency for example we can
add a denomination or value to every
coin so coins will not all have equal
value economically but people can hold a
different coins of different
denominations it clearly needed and to
do that we augmented the data structure
with some additional values I will not
go into the details we also change this
your knowledge proof to check those
values if we want to enable direct
transfers of payments between people
then we need additional machinery we
need to be able to somehow encode a coin
in a way that can be decoded only by
designated recipients and then have the
recipient know that this coin is
addressed to him so and only that
recipient can then continue using that
coin for subsequent transaction and that
requires some keys to identify people
every user would have a private key and
a public key and these keys go into a
much larger tuple with additional
relations
we won't go into the details they are
you can find them all in this euro cache
paper and the subsequent evolution in
the C cash specification let me just say
that everything here can be abstracted
into a transaction that subsumes all the
things that need need to be done in a
Bitcoin like digital currency we call
this a poor transaction in the paper it
consumes to all zero zero cash coins and
it creates or means to new zero cash
coins and it also can withdraw some of
the that hidden money into public
bitcoins that's in case you need to pay
transaction fees and such and then you
also get instructions on how much value
to send to each distinct to each output
coin in using the extended scheme that
we
we've just seen is glimpsed that lets us
address calls to specific people in how
much to send them and the results
fulfill the instructions and then
everything gets packed into something
that goes on the blockchain consisting
of the serial numbers of the consumed
coins to tell everybody hey
these are consuming if you ever see the
serial numbers against this then this
regarding this is a double spend attempt
there's the commitments of the new coins
and there's a zero knowledge proof that
everything held and in particular that
the sum of the old coins is consistent
with some of the newly produced coins so
this is a non-trivial system actually
implementing this is a long exercise it
starts with an implementation of the
snark using lips naka library that we
developed then we have to create the
specifically tuples and relations for a
four zero cash and express our
computation that a function that checks
Merkle trees and sums and so forth we
need to express them in a particular
language of constraints that leave snark
can consume all of this is encapsulated
into a library and then there is a
variant of Bitcoin that integrates the
old Bitcoin Bitcoin code called Bitcoin
D with libs your cash and in the
academic paper we had a network
simulation showing that everything can
run with adequate parameters and
efficiency to support something that is
Bitcoin scale nowadays we actually have
a test network with thousands of users
worldwide who are using that in the
evolution of this architecture and it's
it supports the efficiency requirements
in terms of security well so far so good
I should mention the obvious all of this
is very carefully analyzed what I've
just sketched here in in the paper and
spare
is very precisely specified up to the
last bit and there are security
properties are precisely defined and
proven so I was hoping to say something
about how stocks are constructed but it
doesn't look like the time constraints
will allow that so let me just say one
thing that is important to know in some
applications zero cash is one of them
and then say few words about where
snacks come from in the grand scheme of
things in techniques so we are in the NP
setting and we want snacks to look like
this
sorry that's redundant okay
but actually they look like this in
order to use the most efficient snacks
available those on the bottom-left of
the preceding slide we need to create
those system parameters or public
parameters
that's something essential to the way
the scheme works it you can think about
those parameters as sort of building a
template of what the computation should
look like in encrypted form and then the
actual proof shows that a particular
claim in witness fall into that template
so the computation is of the template
takes roughly as long as proving and
which is much much slower than the
native computation I I should have
mentioned this before proving is much
much slower in the native computation
for example this gnarrk
for zero cache take about a minute to
produce a proof for whereas if you just
blindly trusted the consumer it would
take if a fraction of a millisecond but
back here so there's the generator and
generator produces keys a proving key
and a very fine key that will be used
but
parties later so you have to take care
of this generation you have to do it in
a secure way for example in zero cash
this is a big deal because any
compromise of those probing keys could
lead to a counterfeiting of coins so
there was actually very complicated
cryptographic ceremony done with the
multi-party computation involving
multiple nodes that participate in order
to create those keys in the guarantees
that if even at least one of them is
honest and deletes his transient secrets
then the result is safe to use and the
soundness of the snark holes that's one
way to approach it there are also many
other variants of snarks that I will not
go into beside this question of whether
the public parameters exist or not they
may or may not depend on the choice of
function and it be expensive or cheap
there's a question of who can verify
this snarks or not we're going to for
now focus on the particular most natural
a a definition of snark which is exactly
what you would expect from the
applications except that it does have a
DES trusted setup which is something we
have to manage now these snacks have
involved marvelously since their
inception in 2010 we buy wonderful paper
by year's growth he first showed how
pre-processing snarks can be built in
what in how they improve sales and
parameters most strikingly succinct Ness
and without even going into the
specifics you can see that there has
been a lot of progress in the particular
snark that is the most popular nowadays
because it gives the best trade of the
one using live snark is based on papers
by G GPR and PGH are and they're
implement interpretations and tweaks
including by map by us and
a the striking thing is that it proves
it for this snark
are just seven or eight field elements
where the field is that of your typical
elliptic curve so a few hundred bytes
now showing how this works is something
that I would have loved to do here time
did not allow let me give you that
promised glimpse the way all of this
pre-processing snarks work is they start
with an algebraic part where they take
the witness and encode it into a form
that can be probably this
probabilistically checked if form were
if someone actually wrote it down and
you could query it then you could very
easily make sure that the witness is a
correct witness for the claim statement
in moreover the those queries are all
linear functions so the witness is
encoded into into a string then few
linear queries are done by computing
linear combinations of the string and
then with overwhelming probability
whenever the some equations hold on the
result of these queries the
computational claim is correct but the
problem is that we don't this encoding
is too big it's bigger than the witness
so we don't want the approver to send it
over and this is what cryptography comes
into the picture
we are scripto graphic tools to first
encode the queries so the adversaries
can keep the encoded witness the other
side being the cheating prover can keep
the encoded a witness to himself and
when he gets the kept the queries in
encrypted form they don't know what's
being asked and therefore they can't try
to fool the verifier in how he answers
so we use encrypted queries to prevent a
adaptively adaptive choice of the of a
false witness of false encoded witness
and then moreover remember that the
algebraic part needed linear queries and
we're going to force queries to be
linear by using some additional
properties of the encryption scheme and
lastly because the queries are encrypted
necessarily the answers to the queries
from the prover to the verifier are also
encrypted and that means that no one
else can check them so we want to use
pairings on elliptic curves which we are
grateful to them to let anyone publicly
verify the requisite relations how are
we doing on time
so this is what it looks like at the end
of the day if you shed away all pretense
of obstruction and use a few convenient
functions it ends up being a lot of
field arithmetic expressing low degree
extensions and evaluations of
polynomials on the algebraic part and
expressing that special encryption
scheme on the cryptographic part yeah so
that's a that a slide and many more
results are actually implemented
nowadays in running code we are no
longer in the realm of theory we have
implementations from Microsoft the
Pinocchio and Geppetto system Microsoft
and Kors we have leap snark by my
co-authors and me in a future lab we
call skipper lab for succinct private
sing oh by succinct computational
integrity in privacy and there's even
someone who took lip snark and re
implemented it in a different dialect of
C++ and called it snark lib and these
are just the cryptographic backends
this is these things consume a low-level
representation of the circus you want
and apply various snacks to it lipsmack
supports four or five there is no
explain of this form in several more
extended forms now i would be happy to
but sorry Oh TVC oh dear that is very
well then it did the slide obliges this
is copy and pasted form a tutorial for
sufficiently large value of tomorrow so
there are a there are also a various
ways to create those programs those
functions those constraints that we need
in order to use the snarks we've talked
about verifying miracle trees and sums
how is that expressed for the snarks is
expressed as a by linear constraints
over variables you can think about it as
something very close to our with Matic
circuit representation but you don't
want such low level representations like
the underlying quadratic arithmetic
programs or the arithmetic circuits we
prefer something more UMaine like
boolean circuits you want to claim that
some boolean circuit accept some inputs
or C programs even better we want to say
that the C program executed on some
input and that that we decide and some
other input that we know but don't
reveal outputs some output that we can
so the claim is about the function the
input that we decided and the output and
it expresses the fact that the C program
a has that has that the that property
according to the C language semantics
but would be convenient for programmers
but is a far cry from arithmetic
circuits
and of course ideally we would want to
represent high high level things like a
monetary transaction is correct
according to someone's financial records
so this would be of course a chain of
reductions we have essentially covered
this reduction and I want to tell you a
little bit about how about what we did
to get from here to that and from here
to that so let's talk about snacks for
general C programs this is a the
progress over time it starts with starts
with theoretical feasibility results and
fast forward many papers we now I have a
snacks for general C program of any size
and they can run for any amount of time
and we can even have them talk to each
other in the distributed computation
that discussed later and it's easy to
verify the results of that C program
regardless of its size and running time
and this is actually implemented in
working prototypes the one thing that I
did not dare a check is the question of
fast proofing because there is many
orders of magnitude slowdown in this
cases well in this case due to both the
underlying snark
in the reduction from C programs now the
implementation of this is a non-trivial
affair that was by itself a project that
started with interesting theory
questions and culminated in working
systems the bottom line is that the
correct execution of any C program can
be verified in a few milliseconds and in
a few hundred bytes and it's getting
this creates many questions the biggest
one of this is how to how to handle
variable control flow and random access
memory because if you have just a
straight line program with no random
acts
you could just go instruction by
instruction or the statement by state
when they translate into our thematic
circuits that's the approach that other
systems like Pinocchio and Jupiter took
that can be a fairly tight reduction
it's it's a great way to do things for
that class of programs but once you have
random access memory what do you do
expressing them has huge multiplexers
will be horribly inefficient what about
a conditional jumps loop and so forth so
the way we tackle the problem is by
creating a compiler from C programs into
assembly code of a new virtual a
processor that we defined call tiny ROM
and then we build circuits arithmetic
circuits that implement a tiny run
interpreter conceptually similar to what
you would do in the VHDL design for a
new processor and then we finish the
reduction all the way down to the snarks
the compiler is built on GCC using a new
GCC architecture and it supports all the
standard functionality of C not all the
libraries because some of them talk
about things that are outside our
machine model but all language
constructs are supported this is the
specification of the of the processor it
has just the bare essentials and it
strikes a good trade-off between
efficient compilation and running time
in terms of virtual cycles on one hand
in the reduction from the circuit the
sorry from the specification of the
processor to us or to an arithmetic
circuit we don't have a shuttle 56 but
it is a natural extension yes you could
add a accelerators let me skip that due
to the time but as you can glimpse
that's non-trivial architecture too in
the theoretical heart of the matter is a
way to take a the random exercise and
somehow route them on a permutation and
network in order to express them as an
arithmetic circuit with just local
constraints but that's tomorrow what I
would like to mention in the few
remaining minutes is the generalization
of snarks to distributed computation
because just one node isn't enough and
part of our motivation was the fact that
people talk to each other on and on and
zero cash as a distributed network sort
of glues together vanilla snarks using a
blockchain to make sure that everybody
has verified all the previous narcs but
we could actually do this directly
without a blockchain and you get many of
the properties though not all the ideas
what we call proof carrying data you
have a distributed computation
consisting of nodes producing and
consuming inputs on an directed acyclic
graph of computation and they don't
trust each other at all right that's
that's the assumption we would like to
make the worst case and our goal is not
to bother make sure making sure that
they were all purchased at verified
suppliers but rather to make sure that
they all produce the right result this
is what we really care about so we're
going to augment every message with the
proof that this measured message
complies with a prescribed policy of the
system and the messages can be verified
locally and moreover every message
attests that all of the history complies
as well so you don't have to go and you
don't ever have to go back so just
taking this proof tells me that this is
the result of a long computation or
footsteps are compliant now what do I
mean by compliant right as a strange
word and why compliant I mean that there
is a precise functional specification
that says what relations between inputs
outputs
optional additional inputs is allowed
there is a predicate a compliance
predicate expressed in your favorite
language see circuits whatever and a it
tells you what it means for something to
be locally compliant and then once
you've decided on the compliance
predicate we say that every node is
compliant if it fulfills that predicate
a distributed computation is compliant
if it all nodes fulfill the predicate
and the output is compliant if it's
output of some distributed computation
that is compliant so the first thing to
say is a yes we can do that we can
actually build BCD and leap snark
actually implements it and establishing
under what conditions it actually exists
is another line of theoretical research
that we will discuss tomorrow and the
other question is what is it good for
and there are many interesting examples
like I can say within my network or
within my organization only specific
programs can run and I want proofs of
that that every value that passes way
between nodes is there is compliant in
that sense or my nodes are only allowed
to run programs they signed by the
sysadmin
I can use this for MapReduce
applications for cluster computing a
prototype that we build having a very
fully verified MapReduce that it tells
you that the result of some big
computation whose input there is a
commitment to are the claimed ones think
about some huge query on a medical
database you want to trust the result
you want to proof but there's also a
matter of privacy so the proof is your
knowledge and it reveals nothing about
the values except that they were on the
correct database as summarized in some
hash commitment
another system that will be using PCD is
for authentication authentication of
images photographic images you want to
show that a image is authentic indeed
captured by a camera and you want to
allow some transformations to happen
maybe this is a dating website so people
are allowed to edit their images by
cropping the messy bedroom behind them
but they must not heaven forbid to
change the aspect ratio so how can we
express that and enforce that terms are
the disciplines being an open problem
for more than a decade with the about a
dozen papers coming mainly from the
image processing community which try to
tackle this but there is ad hoc
techniques the system will build called
photo proof uses cryptographic two tools
to solve the problem generically once
the signing key is embedded in the
camera we can say that whenever you edit
an image you'd create a proof that you
correctly edited the image that is you
complied with the list of allowed image
transformations and moreover you edited
an image that it is self compliant in
the same sense
and then the final viewer can verify the
result final verification is very
lightweight and while editing you would
need to create proofs on the fly in this
change structure whereas as soon as you
try to make it to claim a false
statement for example claim authenticity
of something that was airbrushed you
would never be able to produce a
convincing proof so conceptually think
of JPEG images on facebook or with
dating websites as having an extra exif
header giving the snark proof that these
are compliant with the site's policy
and one last ongoing project and I want
to finish with this one because I think
it really drives in the a conceptual
transition that I'm advocating many fuel
must have seen those logic kids where
you get a end gate as a box and then or
gate as a box and you can build circuits
and that's a great way to teach students
or kids the basics of logical circuits
so the problem with that is that is you
cannot trust the result and
unfortunately that problem applies not
just to those toy kids but also to the
state of the art VLSI technology you're
supposed to trust the manufacturer and
hope for the best we've seen recent
fascinating papers about IC Trojans and
how a few errant dopant atoms in the
wrong transistors can create a Trojan
horse
so good luck verifying that but imagine
instead that you completely don't care
about performance at all and moreover
that you could create a this kind of
authenticated logic gates that you can
wire together you tell them hey you you
should do a secure end and you should do
a secure NAND and you let them run
software which implements the proof
carrying data for the compliance
predicate that enforces that circuit so
the compliance would say that at every
point in time the evolution of this
circuit which can have cycles and state
the evolution of this circuit maintains
the invariant that every gate operated
correctly and moreover operated on the
inputs given by other gates who also
operated correctly with respect to some
specific input given to the input gates
of the circuit so this this actually
works it's grossly inefficient because
every gate is implemented by cell phone
in this prototype but
but but it clarifies the basic concept
that we can do authenticated computation
we can trust result of results of
computation we are haggling over the
price but this is the most general thing
you can imagine this is why the citation
is missing this is very new ongoing work
with my student Gaylord Roth so the on
this brand of cell phones it takes on
the order of a minute for a purpose of
propagation delay so to speak yeah
that's a strange unit for propagation
delay but it scales in the sense that if
you did it by hand then at some point in
time you'd need to get to grab some food
or run out with your life span whereas
this can compute indefinitely and we
expected constants to improve so some
discussion clearly we wanted to improve
performance we want to be today do it by
hand barrier for this is the most
extreme case that we ever built doing
the whole snark proof parry gate that
lets say huge overhead for particular
applications where we really care about
performance like zero cache we strip
away many layers of abstractions and
tailor things and then the overheads are
a few orders of magnitude compared to
native execution which may be worth it
when you have no alternative there is no
other known way to create for example
crypto currencies or authentication
schemes with the claim properties we
want to get rid of the pre-processing
and trusted set up that I alluded to we
would love to go back to the old schemes
that don't have it and we are actively
working on in the lab we have a
prototype that implements that schemes
and we have a an implementation of tiny
ROM in the C compiler for that
implementation as well without process
processing unfortunately performance is
still far from the state-of-the-art
pre-processing snow
yeah some two weeks but here then we are
eagerly looking for applications I
mentioned just a few there actually by
now I think over ten research groups
worldwide that you sleep snack for all
sort of applications many of them are in
the cryptocurrency arena but doing
different things then adding privacy in
the sense I described some are
completely different and a this is very
exciting to be part of facilitating a
substrate the lodge of fascinating
research and lastly we want to help
users build those applications which
raises it very interesting questions in
the realm of programming languages for
expressing statements they behave
strangely compared to traditional
computation for example in a certain
sets you get non-deterministic advice
for free but you still can trust it and
bilinear operations are are the basic
ingredients so linear combinations are
for free and you want to optimize for
that so there are good questions there
there is the crucial question of being
sure that the statements that we prove
that compliance predicates that that
whoops that we verify actually correct
in the sense that they have the
properties we think they do and that's a
question for the formal analysis people
among us and their questions of how to
integrate this power in this expressive
power into larger systems built in the
old school just trust the node the
paradigm and in this direction there is
ongoing work where we look at verifying
the that Java classes for example have
the correct provenance according to the
Java semantics which is something that
you cannot trust if you just import them
from a network
so I hope that I've made the case that
snarks are a paradigm shift in security
at least in those scenarios where they
are sufficiently practical and I hope to
enlist you to the effort to improve and
use them thank you so many details are
forthcoming and the first of which
should appear today I believe at the
broad level there was a committee each
user each participant in the committee
was a reputable party so it would be
extremely surprising if all of them
colluded in in keeping secrets that they
should not so that's the first line of
defense and of course they could have
been just hacked by all those
vulnerabilities were enumerated at the
very beginning so we took very extreme
OPSEC measures at each of these sites in
order to have for example in air gap
between the secrets and anything else
keep append-only lobes of every
individual transaction verify the code
in every way that was feasible and so
forth and all the details of that
including the code including those logs
and the participant statements will be
fully published
as the FBI Cabiria said this is too so
Becca Turing Z cash in in in in this
scheme and within the scenario that was
constructed and documented it will be
reviewed it's not something that I would
know how to do all the proofs say that
under certain assumptions it's it's
infeasible and the I hope that the OPSEC
in of the ceremony will convince people
that those assumptions were fulfilled
what overlap there's been so far between
the verifiable the relation between
quantum computing and verifiable
computation that's like Batman vs
Superman right well to spoil the fun the
battle would end very quickly in the
sense that at the moment we do not have
any snacks at a quantum resistant
earlier I alluded to cryptographic
properties that we acquire from that
encryption scheme used to encrypt the
queries in the snark the only scheme
that that we know of that has these
properties is based on discrete log and
let me actually change my statement
there is no efficient snark of the
pre-processing kind that is quantum
resistant if you go back to those
old-school snarks proposed by Sylvia
McCauley and Killian
they rely just on probabilistically
checkable proofs which are it's provable
a algebraic properties under no
assumptions and
in if you believe in random Oracle's if
you believe in very random functions
they can be quantum resistant which I
think everyone does then then that's all
it needs if you don't then there is a
more precise characterization of what's
needed in the form of extractable
collision resistant hash --is and there
we have the better theoretical
understanding but actually I'm not sure
what's the state of the art about post
quantum extractable collision resistant
ashes that's a great question so the
double spending mechanism in zero cash
has similar properties to that of
Bitcoin in the sense that whenever the
output of the transaction is consumed
and should never be consumed again this
is written in the letter it's written in
a different way in our case it would be
the serial number right but once it's
written everyone who sees that ledger
will know that it's and I will spend so
the remaining question is does everyone
see the same ledger which is the
question of the distributed consensus
layer of Bitcoin and that is nearly
orthogonal to the one we've been
discussing it's worth pointing out and
even have to set up as problematic you
would have problems with coins being
double spending things like that but
privacy would not be hurt right let's
that's an important point thank you Dan
the trusted setup is required to
ensuring the soundness of the snark and
sniffing that coins will not be
counterfeited and we saw in the scheme
where that comes in if someone could
convince your first false statement they
could withdraw a commitment that that is
not really in the in the ledger in
miracle tree
however the zero knowledge property is
unconditional this is what's called
statistical to your knowledge basically
all the in that the zero knowledge proof
contains all that people can see on the
ledger is a bunch of values that are
completely random conditioned on that
that they are correct proof so there's
no further information to learn except
that the proof is correct answer my
question back door so if if relator
agency were interested in violating the
privacy of users rather than stealing
all their money then the proofs say they
can't do that also if the initialization
process was bad to her he wouldn't be
able to detect it because there isn't
enough information in the public ledger
to do that right the verification of the
of the trusted setup ceremony is
completely independent of the ledger we
use old-school mechanisms to convince
people of what went on like having a
surveillance cameras at the nodes that
participated in the ceremony running
around the clock having journalists
on-site reviewing everything taking has
changes of everything that goes on in
posting them on Twitter as some of you
may have noticed and yes these are
out-of-band
channels but in conjunction they would
be extremely hard to fake
did you use photo coupon spray on Sam
288 bytes and a verification proof what
kind of processor so the size of the
proof is independent of the processor
it's just those seven right field
elements that I mentioned earlier it's
only function of which snug construction
you use and what security parameters you
choose in terms of the assumptions on
the hardness of discrete log in the
underlying curve and so forth okay so
the number that does require that is the
running time so the numbers I gave we're
four different architectures let's see
for the force four zero cash creating
the proof it takes under a minute on a
typical desktop CPU and for the you four
for the variant of tiny ROM a that can
run forever without without a memory
blow updated that best-case on the on
the bottom line vary in the performance
is about one tenth of an Hertz one psych
one cycle every ten minutes or every ten
seconds on a typical server processor
for the even more extreme more wasteful
version of using cell phones those were
amazing mx-5 phones but the bottom line
is that when the computation is simple
enough when you've managed to distill
your security property into a small
simple specification as in zero cash or
then the running times are typically on
the order of seconds or many
on a regular processors if you do
something with high higher level of
obstruction you lose orders of magnitude
and if you do something that is a more
heavy weight in the input size like on
the image processing of photo proof and
then you would in running time would be
commensurate to that but from photo
proof for small images it is on the
order of minutes or tens of minutes now
something you'd run in the background
I'll be happy to give more specific
numbers for any specific scenario
you